nobody has ever measured how much
plastic pollution is in the sea and on
the beaches here around the lammu
islands off kenya's northern coast
the campaigners on board this sailing
boat want to give it a go
it's called the flip-floppy and made
from recycled plastic waste named after
the plastic sandals that cover it we're
interested in understanding how we can
create a circular economy for plastic
waste here in in a local
environment like this so to do that we
have to understand how much plastic is
here we have to understand
how much people know about this issue
the flip-floppy crew members campaign
against the use of single-use plastics
and try to find ways for people to reuse
plastic waste
the flip floppy is the first sailing
boat of its kind in the world and this
survey is the first of its kind to ever
take place in this part of the indian
ocean the crew say they don't know
exactly how much plastic pollution is in
the ocean on the beaches or in the
mangroves but they say they're sure
that there's a lot
and they're right on every island
they've stopped plastic bottles litter
the mangrove swamps that line the shores
by roping off squares and collecting and
weighing the plastic in each
they can estimate how many tons are here
and then share ideas with the
communities of what to do with it all
my moon shay already collects plastic
waste from the beaches
it has benefits it has helped us we
collect the bottles and we put it in
other plastics that we collect from the
ocean we've made plastic blocks and
built a house from them
maimuna and her neighbours have joined
plastic recycling projects before
they showed us what they've built from
the waste they've collected
but the waste on the beaches is only
part of the problem
this device collects tiny plastic
particles from the sea
the samples will be sent to a lab to
find out if the water here is as
polluted as the coastline
bahati myoma has traveled from tanzania
to help with the research he says the
particles are disastrous for fish if a
plastic looks like
food for a certain speech it will be
consumed and we understand that plastic
cannot be digested this fish will end up
occurring either dying or their
reproductive reproductive ability will
be hampered
for more than a thousand years seasonal
winds carried traders in daos across the
indian ocean
today campaigners say the same winds are
bringing plastic waste from as far away
as china to these islands
they hope the flip floppy project will
help the people living on them to deal
with the growing challenge of plastic
waste
well malcolm webb joins us now live from
nairobi malcolm so what does it mean
that this resolution is now being passed
what will it do
the resolution uh commits the
signatories and there were no objections
all of the
governments represented there uh i've
agreed to this resolution and they
have committed to within the next two
years
negotiate and implement a legally
binding treaty
on plastics which is expected to
restrict plastic production
and to also address this issue of
plastic waste now the researchers in the
campaign as we just saw in the story
there
will take some weeks to process the data
to find out how much plastic pollution
is in that part of the indian ocean but
it's well known globally that plastic
pollution levels are soaring
increasing exponentially projected too
in the coming
decades plastics contaminated the food
chain it's destroying marine
environments
and campaigners are very excited they
say this resolution is a major step
forward in empowering uh governments to
tackle the companies that are profiting
uh from the status quo and legislate in
a way that will actually uh give a
chance uh of reducing this uh escalating
kind of pollution
all right malcolm webb for us in nairobi
thank you